as we go into this which probably is
going to be a recession might be a
depression how do you think about
overcoming the obstacles that are gonna
come your way how do you avoid falling
into the trap of thinking that you know
everything already like how do you stay
nimble um that's a good question you
know at this point our company's so big
that you have a lot of friends who are
solar entrepreneurs and they're able to
be nimble because like it's just them
and they can you know now we've got 400
plus employees and it's a it's harder to
B to be nimble I think it's been
interesting because I've been trying to
trying to figure that out and you know
one of our mutual friends Dean Graciosa
I talked to him about this a lot as
everything start hit anything start
shifting and I remember watching him
because I again I'm I'm kind of a
marketing nerd so I remember when I was
in high school I used to sit back and I
would watch input like I remember I
watched Dean on infomercials back when I
was a kid and I would take notes I'm
like wow like the way he said things and
I remember watching as it came up to
like the last big recession kind of
watching all Dean's infomercials in at a
time there was probably I don't know 30
different get rich and real estate
infomercials on TV like anyone who never
flipped a house and they're live for
like I'm an infomercial guru and
teaching people how to do it right and
and then the recession hit and in the
housing market crashed and it went from
like 50 infomercial gurus to like three
down to one and then there was just Dean
and Dean continued running infomercials
the entire thing and then and then and
then beyond and I remember I didn't know
him at the time I remember watching and
just being interested how like he was
the only one still on and so I asked him
later how in the world is you did you
survive when everyone else got got
crushed and he said something super
profound he's like he's a did it shift
I didn't shift my product I mean a
product was still the same he's like I
shifted our market in my product he said
everyone else was speaking very
aspirational like how do we how do we
create this thing you know how do we how
do we get rich how to make money like
things like that he's like I shipped it
for me an aspirational to to looking at
my business more like a life preserver
like I like how do you how do you
protect yourself how this product can
can protect you and and so as we started
coming in this thing I realized the same
thing like in fact I talked a little
about in traffic seekers I talked about
the fact that when any customers coming
to you they're they're either moving
towards you and they're moving toward
do in one two directions though they're
moving towards pleasure or they're
moving away from pain right it's like
they're coming to me because they want
started business when I get rich do they
want to make money or they want to
whatever or they're coming to me because
I hate my boss I need to got this pain
like it's just a miserable I need to
needy out of pain if you look at the
economy over the last you know seven or
eight years most because for most people
spend pretty good most people are buying
any product or service whether it be
Fitness health you know business
anything for that matter it's like
they're buying it because if I move
towards pleasure but you know a couple
weeks ago everything shifted where
people are on pain now I think the
companies are gonna survive and be
nimbler ones I understand a ship their
messaging where it's like how can how
can the product or service I sell how
does it get somebody out of pain and
that's the marketing the messaging
people need and they want right now and
it's funny cuz like as I was launching
the the traffic I literally we launched
the book the same day that President
Trump told everyone to go home and if
you look like my marketing campaign
ahead of time it was like you know how
we built this hundred hundred million
dollar your company and how traffic how
much traffic we get all these things and
then I was like that is the wrong
message right now and so we literally
like my team on my right everything
every ad we've written every pre-cell
every video like just delete them all
we're redoing everything I'm like this
is the messaging the messaging is and
which are talking about I got a buddy
down the street who owns a local waffle
place the best waffles in the world if
you're kind of boys I'll take you there
and and he opened the same day that the
whole recession happened and I was crazy
because you look a like he's got his
business he opens the doors and it's the
same day that they're literally traffic
you know usually restaurants you you
have cars to write physical traffic
driving by and people come and they they
come in the evenings like the traffic
stopped and what happens on companies
they just they die like traffic is the
lifeblood of a company and so the whole
messaging shifted to like look like if
you want to survive during these times
then thrive on the other side of this
like you have to master trafficking
customers in Guinea people in like this
is literally your company's life
preserver
during these uncertain times so all the
messaging shifted the ads shifted the
like the mag everything shifted and and
you know the book launch has done
insanely well everything is kind of come
from that but but it all came from like
shifting the message from towards
pleasure to understanding it we're in a
time of moving people away from pain I
think that the companies to understand
that and understand that shift and
messaging are the ones they're gonna
that are gonna really win during this
this time it's just like now on the
Panda
right and I'm just using myself as a
parallel enhance or not the Donald Trump
but now because of the fact that I'm
always trying to move in a way that's
independent revolutionary and it's
always a fight for me I'm used to moving
around in the wool you understand what
I'm saying I'm used to having a business
model that's not dependent on other
people telling me what to do I'm used to
being able to stay home basically every
way that everyone has to live now I'm
used to doing that so I'm thriving why
everyone's trying to figure it out I'm
already used to it the same thing is
happening with women you know because
the playing field is now becoming level
right well the opportunities are now the
same now women who used to not have the
same opportunities that do I like I'm a
bust they ass and now men that I used to
be in given privileged opportunity don't
have it and now they really got to work
for it so they're crumbling and these
women is shining you know in the middle
of a war the real generals that I'm
seeing or female the ones that are doing
it right the ones that are holding it
down or female so many people are stuck
at home and a lot of people now they're
starting to think about okay the jobs
that I used to have they are no longer
there what do I need to do what new
skills what new knowledge do I need to
acquire in order to equip myself in
order to find a job because most of
those jobs may not be available anymore
business owners entrepreneurs we are
also thinking about okay what new
insights do I need what help do I need
to modify or pivot my business model I
need to do something so people are
seeking learning opportunities
especially learning opportunities from
home that they don't have to go
somewhere they don't have to go to an
event necessarily that they could learn
just from their computers so e-learning
is huge and a lot of students are
learning from home a lot of them off
learning just virtually this will create
a new behavior after this a lot of
students
a lot of people will question do I
actually need to go to school will going
to school getting that degree will that
even prepare me for the future and now
the world has changed so dramatically in
a short period of time this message I've
been giving you guys for years about
what to do and how to grow your business
it has never been more true than it is
right now okay this is what works bad
news don't work okay bad news don't work
what's gonna work right now for you is
getting through this economy and I
promise you I can get you through this
economy if you're scared right now you
should be I'm scared
I'm worried every day every single day I
wake up worried how long is this gonna
last how deeps are gonna be okay my real
estate is in perfect shape but every
piece of real estate around me the
retail store the movie Center the
Aventura Mall right here they're saying
they're saying that as many as 40% of
the malls in America could fail maybe
more every failure in your community
puts you and your company at risk this
is what I'm scared about everyday not my
stuff failing I'm worried about
everything around me am i getting cut
off Johnny are you good okay I'm worried
about everything around me failing okay
what works right now is you need a plan
okay persistence is the way through all
these problems you have to you have to
show up and work number two okay you got
to make real contacts today I was on the
phone this morning real contacts okay I
was on the phone with my friend Tim
Grover - that's it Tim then go on
Instagram in any given moment they got
everybody think they're doing something
getting likes and comments viewers
viewership on lines up great but is that
a real contact with your buyer is it a
real contact okay first thing I'm doing
each day is making a list of people that
I can make real contacts with set up a
real appointment with actually talk
about something and number two number
two make an offer in these contacts you
need to make an offer
this is what I've been telling people to
do for years nothing's changed him with
that I'm just gonna do it 10 times
bigger and more
I'm gonna go wider and deep and I'm
gonna insist on it so many of your
making contacts right now every day I'm
getting emails during this Cove in 19
moment we wanted to reach out and see if
we could be of assistance to you how can
we help you what can we do for you how
can we be of assistance how can we you
service you make real contacts and make
an offer okay quit just offering help
there's got to be an offer that you make
where they get to exchange with you
something that you're doing for them and
number three never before in my lifetime
I've always said this was the Holy Grail
now it's the Holy Grail on steroids you
have to follow up today your cycles are
going to be longer because of the
uncertainty when uncertainty goes down
when uncertainty goes down
okay so dude does your ability to close
the deal when then when certainty drops
with your customers your outbound
activity has to go up to offset the
amount of uncertainty in the market
place make real contacts make real
offers follow up those organization
persistence right now team work is going
to be key I got something bouncing up in
the middle of screen Johnny I don't know
if you see it it's gonna be the key to
you getting through this there's gonna
be a long cycle folks I think you need
to think about I think you need to think
about what are we in we're in May 2000
to 2020 look if this thing is over in
January of 2022 I think you're gonna be
lucky if you're out of work right now
you need to go get a job today
make real contacts with real people
hiring people okay
well grant nobody's hiring anybody oh
yeah you need to make contact with a
real person with a real person that can
hire you they might not be hiring or
they not paying if you're a good person
and you can help them you can drive
revenue and you can bring customers I
guarantee you can get a job right now
every company in the world wants
customers every customer in the world
wants
new if you want more advice wisdom
guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me I hope you
find it valuable continue to believe and
I'll see you there
Uber's but you know you don't need to be
it over to drive it because uber doesn't
need you